[Música]
olá todas bom se o danny falou portugal
que ele vinha aqui para o jornal é como
podem perceber pelo meu sotaque
eu vendo um planeta distante ea minha
nave espacial aterrou no brasil no rio
de janeiro e e pronto viajando por dois
países
viajando e vivendo por 12 países é isso
que me toca agora falar não é vivendo há
três anos em barcelona
inclusive eu vi uma semana antes aqui
para portugal para reaprender o
português é porque não sei como as
pessoas normais e saudáveis como vocês
fazem para aprender tantas línguas
estrangeiras e manter a língua materna o
que está passando comigo é estão
perdendo a minha língua materna e
falando todas as línguas ao mesmo tempo
um fatal não é outra coisa também
depois do kung fu 2010 e 2011 não sei o
que estou fazendo aqui
deus tenha encerrado até 10x de todos
voltarem para casa felizes e com
esperança que podemos transformar o
mundo essas crianças e esses jovens
estou encantado quando recebi o convite
para participar do teste
eu achei um pouco estranho estava numa
ilha no meio do panamá no meio do
pacífico no panamá e aceitei primeira
não é mas pensava tantas pessoas
interessantes que vêm participar do ted
o que poderei fazer eu para acrescentar
a tantas pessoas que participam e quando
cheguei aqui descobrir o filipe que
apresentou agora é meu ex aluno de surf
ele fez um pacto comigo só vai subir
agora ao cenário e promete aulas de
santo e vitalícias e eu tive que pactuar
com eliel felipe garante tatiana temos
aquela cessar vitalícias bem como o
passe como todos vocês como todos nós
fomos escolarizados por décadas e além
de ser regularizado como crianças e
ainda insiste no erro e tome professor
também educador
o educador educar a dor não eu sou
educado amor eu busco amor e passar para
as pessoas isso não é transmitir a
essência e como educa amor resistente do
processo pedagógico convencional eu
estruturei durante um par de meses
comecei a me dar conta da roubada e
remetidas via que é o teste ela tem
estruturado que essa coisa de dizer
escolarização eu vou chegar a lima tem
uma branca e não vou conseguir falar ou
bloquear e pronto fiz a minha o meu
dever de casa né meu
a minha tarefa é saber bom eu necessito
de de óculos é pra dar uma seriedade não
é falar de escolarização para aparentar
um pouco de de educador que na verdade
eu não necessita de óculos eu tenho o
braço curto e não consigo distanciar um
pouco pra poder e da vista cansada mas
mas pronto é a escola convencional e as
professoras e professores que me
acompanharam me ensinaram que
mentalmente eu tenho que organizar mas
não é
pronto organizei minha livreto meses de
trabalho é investigar e todos educadores
e educadoras que são referência para mim
e fui passando com as minhas palavras
quando aquela coisa de copiar noite
passada aqui e foi transformado por que
afinal em título um desejo colonizadora
e fiz o meu trabalho pessoal e pronto
tem os resumos e coisas apontadas com
canetas e tal
tudo muito bem organizado estruturado e
na semana passada quando eu vim a
portugal para praticar o português e até
fazer uma passagem é dessa minha
apresentação eu fui jantar com três
amigos aqui em portugal um brasileiro um
português eo vinho português
éramos quatro na mesa não é e quando eu
fiz a apresentação pra eles ficaram me
olhando assim alex quando a apresentação
na próxima semana ele olha tu não vais
querer escutar o que tem pra te dizer a
crítica que vamos fazer aqui
não mas vai lá críticas construtivas mas
somos amigos fala olha o texto é muito
bonito tá muito teórico tá muito
pedagógico da convincente mas não é isto
eu não vejo alex aquino nesse texto
seria muito interessante para uma
revista científica pedagógica e
educacional o convencional tradicional
mas não é isto e depois desse jantar eu
optei de uma estratégia kamikaze de
desvalorização e mais do que dizes
colorização porque é um termo que vem
para a negação não é dizer escola
escolarização é ação pela escola eu
estou em paz com a escola com as minhas
professoras e professores mas e opto
pela vida aprender pela vida
vivenciar eu proponho um novo termo ao
invés de escolarização avidar ização pra
abrimos para a vida aí que está o nosso
a nossa aprendizagem verdadeira então
todo esse roteiro esse processo de
esvaziarmos que o passeio durante um par
de meses
esvaziaram de tudo aquilo que não serve
para nada e para abrir espaço que
realmente importa desconectar da mente
que também é importante há razão para
mediar mas conectar com o meu coração
o que eu chamo conectar com a wifi e
técnica que todos nós podemos conectar
todos nós temos este rutter que conecta
qualifyer e técnica
então isso agora não
não faz sentido mais não é
a devida utilização
eu deixei de lado todos esses meses de
ensaio de memorização repetição
mecanização e filho agora um movimento
inverso para dentro do meu coração
ao invés de memorizar recordar voltar a
passar pelo coração aprendizagem
verdadeira necessita de moção exige nos
todos os sentidos abertos e disponíveis
para poder absorver tudo o que a vida
pode nos oferecer e aprendizagem está
tudo isso que está à nossa volta e temos
de estar conectados para isso
eu deixei de lado a educação
convencional ou alternativa à escola uma
maneira geral e optei em vivenciar o mar
eu sou brasileiro do rio de janeiro e
kristi julgando à beira mar descobriu
cef e depois à vela
o mar é minha vida e optei compartilha
essa vivência com crianças jovens e
adultos gente grande também o mar é o
que preenche o meu coração e se assim é
o marketing compartilhar com vocês no
mar no site por exemplo a nossa tábua de
salvação é a prancha e temos um lixo uma
espécie de uma cordinha que nos liga à
nossa preencha se caímos em uma onda ou
aprendemos na náutica na vela temos um
colete salva vidas
caso o barco virem que um barco golpe
temos o colete e na vida da nossa vida
diária
o que temos para salvar-nos na vida
meu colete salva vidas é esse o nariz de
palhaço
este é o chuvisco a minha parte mais
bonita e cada um e cada uma de vocês tem
um palhaço dentro de si
basta conectar quando a situação aperta
quando não há mais volta a dar quando
não tem mais o que escaparam como por
exemplo está no palco do telex ter uma
branca fatal acabar de rasgar todo o meu
guião esta minha bóia de salvação a ver
como desenrasco dessas baixo risco da
minha mão amigo alex espera uma história
que era só o joão paulo jô a tema
portugal
agora é bom não haviam poesia a encher o
coração de poesia por exemplo
bem-haja gonzaguinha eu fico com a
pureza da resposta das crianças é a vida
é bonita e é bonita viver e não ter a
vergonha de ser feliz cantar e cantar e
cantar a beleza de ser um eterno
aprendiz
ai meu deus eu sei eu sei que a vida
devia ser bem melhor e será mas isso não
impede que eu repita que é bonita é
bonita e é bonita guapa bom pelo o
relógio aqui temos mais um parelho de
segundos após cantar uma canção senhor
filipe é muito curtinho assim é muito
famosa sim senhora
a ver daqui do meio desse senhor que tem
aqui uma casca de pipoca no dente tom e
se está repito aqui que o pac vai cantar
assim
quem te ensinou a nadar dois meses
quem tem ensino há nada do milho de
pipoca pac foi marinheiro foram os
peixinhos do mar foi marinheiro foram os
peixinhos do mar
quem te ensinou a navegar foi foi
marinheiro foram as ondas do mar
[Música]
todos usaram duas vezes cada padre eo
etoa quarta quem te ensinou a nadar
quem te ensinou a nadar e foi marinheiro
ora os peixe do mar e foi marinheiro
foram os peixes do mar
quem te ensinou a navegar intensiva ou
navegar
fui foi marinheiro foram as ondas do mar
foi marinheiro foram à zona há muitas
graças já tem que subir que a lei que
tem que baixar
mercia é
os convido a buscar o vosso palhaço ea
vossa palhaço interior como brasileiro
eu tive a sorte de crescer e aprender
com os negros na favela no rio de
janeiro e com os indígenas na amazônia
os negros ensinaram que devemos celebrar
a vida e os indígenas dentre muitas
coisas desde o respeito à pachamama em
janeiro para bater ondé gaia a nossa
maio mãe terra respeitá lá sempre
ensinaram me que quando encontramos uma
criança
devemos elevarmos nos altura de uma
criança para olhar nos olhos e acompanhá
lá de um lugar respeituoso e consciente
os indígenas ensinaram que a casa da
criança
chama-se olga militar e também me
ensinaram que é preciso toda uma aldeia
para educar uma criança em que o velho é
o dono da história
o adulto é o dono da aldeia ea criança é
a dona do mundo a responsabilidade de
ser a dona do mundo traz para criança
muitos limites e conseqüências
deixemos que as crianças se frustrem é
fundamental despertar a resiliência
gestionar a frustração a paciência eo
tempo de espera
os indígenas aparas são uma tribo da
amazônia para quem os sonhos constitui
uma parte essencial da sua existência
não possuem chamar porque optam e não
ter uma pessoa que dirige os seus
caminhos
o único que seguem para os seus planos
são os seus sonhos
certa vez o governo dos estados unidos
convidou e sugeriu aos índios que
enviassem alguns dos seus jovens para
estudar nas escolas dos brancos
na carta resposta os indígenas
agradeciam recusando
um trecho da carta das seis nações
salve caboclo aqueles que são sábios
reconhecem que diferentes nações têm
concepções diferentes das coisas e sendo
assim os senhores não ficaram ofendidos
em saber que a vossa idéia de educação
não é a mesma que a nossa
muitos dos nossos jovens guerreiros
foram enviados para as vossas escolas e
aprenderam toda a vossa ciência mas
quando eles voltavam para nós eram mãos
corredores ignorante da vida na floresta
incapaz de suportar o frio ea fome não
sabiam como caçar o animal lutar contra
o inimigo nem construir uma cabana e
falar a nossa língua muito mal
eles eram portanto totalmente inúteis
não serviam como caçadores como
guerreiros como conselheiros para
demonstrar a nossa gratidão
convidamos os senhores que nos enviem
alguns dos seus jovens que lhes ensinar
emos tudo que sabemos e faremos deles
homens e mulheres
salve o povo da floresta e do mar também
o mar sempre fez parte da minha vida
oxalá que seja para sempre uma manhã mas
já o mar que hoje faltam peixes e sobram
dejetos petróleo e microplásticos um mar
de náufragos inocentes fugindo da guerra
covarde criada pela ganância do
capitalismo
ainda assim esse mesmo mar trouxe a paz
o sustento eo equilíbrio ser fã da boa
onda
a minha vida transformou se em honda
pura há muito que se fala dos infinitos
benefícios do sef e da vela ao nível
pedagógico social e de saúde
o que posso dizer vos é que depois que
entrou no mar sai uma pessoa melhor
assim como na vida as ondas desafios vêm
em séries
intervalo de tempo cíclicos se não há
condições
sigo preparando me para quando surgir a
oportunidade de surfar ou pelo contrário
se deparar me com uma onda gigante ea
situação foge completamente o meu
controle
devo flexibilizar e submergir recuperar
forças
identificar o momento certo de voltar à
superfície e seguir remando em direção
ao objetivo encontrar a luz no fim do
tubo surfado a vida tá se bem desliza e
conecta com energia atitude leitura de
onda fluidez e equilíbrio
nunca virei as costas ao mar muito menos
aos seus sonhos
diga não ao paredão ele não visse a
terra lira o tornar e má fé navegar por
mares nunca dantes navegados seguindo
sempre a nossa carta náutica pessoal em
cada mudança de vento ajustar as velas e
mudar de rumo mas sem perder de vista o
teu destino e se apanhar por alguma
tempestade ou total ausência de vento
ter a humildade sabedoria de pararem bom
porto a fazer reparações aguardar pelas
condições favoráveis e tornar a partir
de estar constantemente de braços
abertos ao oceano da vida
a onda perfeita que está esperando em
sua própria vida
ela sorriu pra ter muita remada e põe
pra baixo porque a melhor surfista é
aquela que mais se diverte
[Aplausos]
[Música]